.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Man wurde von Kopf bis Fuss
betrachtet:
"Deine Arme sind etwas dick."
Wir mussten jeden Dienstag
auf die Waage.
Man ist unter ständiger Kontrolle.
Wir haben alles
auf den Sport abgestimmt.
Es wird nicht
nach der Leistung benotet.
Es wurde viel verdreht
und dann noch hintenherum gemacht.
* Ruhige Musik *
Sie haben uns rausgeekelt
und gemobbt.
Anouk, Fabienne und Aline.
Sie waren jahrelang
im Schweizer Nationalkader
Synchronschwimmen,
nahmen an Welt-
und Europameisterschaften teil.
Sie sind drei von vielen Athletinnen,
die in den letzten Monaten
mit uns gesprochen
und Abgründe im Schweizer Sport
aufgezeigt haben.
Die Frage, die sich stellt:
Was läuft falsch
im Synchronschwimmen?
Ihr habt euch dazu entschieden,
eure Geschichte zu erzählen.
Es nimmt mich wunder, warum.
Warum packt ihr heute aus?
Damit sich für die
jüngeren Generationen was ändert.
Damit man ihnen zuhört,
wenn es ein Problem gibt.
Damit andere wissen,
dass sie nicht allein sind.
Uns wurde nie zugehört.
Es ist jetzt Zeit.
Am Anfang war die Faszination.
Für mich war die Freiheit im Wasser
immer ein wichtiges Gefühl.
Anfangs hatte ich immer das Gefühl,
ich fliege.
Man ist so in einer eigenen Welt.
Man muss wirklich
mit dem ganzen Körper arbeiten
und an 3'000 Dinge gleichzeitig
denken.
Aber man kann seine Emotionen
bei der Kür trotzdem ausdrücken.
Alle drei wuchsen im Kanton Bern auf.
Alle drei fingen schon in jüngsten
Jahren mit dem Synchronschwimmen an.
Bald nahmen sie
an den ersten Wettkämpfen teil.
Wir besuchten alle die Sportschule.
Das war alles abgestimmt.
Wir hatten fixe Blockzeiten.
Am Montag war Training
von 8.30 bis 12 Uhr.
Dann ging es von 12.40 bis 16.15 Uhr
direkt in die Schule.
Von dort dann
von 17 bis 21 Uhr ins Training.
Dann morgens Schule,
abends Training.
Am Donnerstag und Freitag
direkt ins Training.
Am Samstagmorgen Training
und am Sonntag hatten wir frei.
Oder Wettkampf, je nachdem.
Die Schule war Nebensache.
- Ja.
Zuerst kam das Training,
dann die Schule,
dann Familie und dann die Freunde.
Also, wir hatten ja v.a. uns.
Für andere hatte man keine Zeit.
- Nein.
Synchronschwimmen verlangt von den
Mädchen und jungen Frauen viel ab.
Die Trainings sind oft hart,
nicht selten
über das erträgliche Mass hinaus.
Für mich fing das in der Nati an.
Wir wurden oft verbal fertiggemacht.
Wenn die Trainerinnen ein Gefühl von
Hierarchie geben und zeigen mussten,
dass sie über uns stehen ...
Machte man etwas schlecht,
wurde man sofort angeschrien.
Wenn man nach 4 Std. Training
extrem müde war,
schauten sie uns von oben herab an
und sagten: "Weisst du, warum?"
"Ich habe mich bemüht.
Es war streng."
"Nein, du siehst megaschwer aus."
Oder: "Weil du zu fett bist."
Wenn man fragte,
ob man eine Pause machen
und am Rand was trinken könne,
hiess es:
"Erst, wenn das perfekt ist."
Und das war dann einfach
bei Trainingsende.
Wenn Nein gesagt wurde,
traute sich niemand,
an den Rand zu gehen
und was zu trinken.
Man wusste,
dass etwas passieren würde.
Das war nicht erlaubt.
Man wird auf das Körperliche
reduziert. Das sagen sie auch.
"Du bist zu fett."
- "Du hast zugenommen."
Genau. Direkte Kommentare wie:
"Du hast megagrosse Brüste."
Wir waren ziemlich jung
und mussten jeden Dienstag
vor dem ganzen Team auf die Waage.
Dann kamen die Kommentare:
"Wie kann das sein?"
"Vor einem Monat hattest du so viel
und jetzt so viel."
"Wenn du erfolgreich sein willst,
musst du aufpassen."
Die Trainerin sagte:
"Das dürft ihr nicht essen."
Und alle standen auf
und legten es zurück.
Das war ...
- Nur schon der Blick,
wenn man mit dem Tablar kam
und die Trainerin dort stand.
Das nimmt dann gefährliche Wege.
- Essstörungen.
Als wir mit der Nati
an der WM waren ...
... hatte gut die Hälfte des Teams
eine Essstörung.
* Düstere Klänge *
Was macht dieser Sport
mit jungen Frauen
und ihrer Beziehung
zum eigenen Körper?
Das wollte Anouk Helfer
genauer wissen
und schrieb ihre Maturaarbeit
über das Thema
Essstörungen im Synchronschwimmen.
Dafür verschickte sie Fragebogen
an Schweizer Trainerinnen
und Schwimmerinnen.
Als ich die Schwimmerinnen fragte,
ob sie Kommentare über ihr Gewicht
oder zum Thema Abnehmen gehört haben
oder dass sie zu fett seien usw.,
sagten sehr viele ...
... dass das passiert sei.
Viel mehr als die Hälfte.
Als ich die Trainerinnen fragte,
ob sie schon mal einen Kommentar
über das Gewicht einer Schwimmerin
gemacht hätten,
sagten viele,
das hätten sie noch nie gemacht.
Irgendetwas stimmt also nicht.
Das waren Trainerinnen
aus der Schweiz,
die die befragten Schwimmerinnen
trainieren.
Es ist offensichtlich:
In diesem Sport
gibt es grundsätzliche Probleme -
auch in Bezug aufs Essen.
Mit gravierenden Folgen
für die Athletinnen.
Das ist doch bei jeder Person so.
Wenn man Kommentare zu seinem Körper
hört, trifft einen das.
Das geht nicht an einem vorbei.
Ja ...
Das ist manchmal nicht so einfach.
Aber irgendwann
gewöhnt man sich daran.
Dann steht man darüber.
Dann kann man versuchen,
es so gut wie möglich auszublenden.
Aber das ist nicht immer so einfach.
(Mutter)
Jetzt brauchen wir noch 75 g ...
Ich habe nie für eine längere Zeit
nichts gegessen
oder darauf geachtet, was ich esse.
Aber das ist in meinem Kopf.
Wenn ich in den Spiegel schaue,
achte ich immer auf die Beine.
Wenn ich etwas viel Schokolade esse,
habe ich ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Das gehört
halt wirklich auch zum Sport.
Das ist schade, weil ...
... es uns von so jung an
beigebracht wird.
Das Fazit ihrer Maturaarbeit:
Die Trainerinnen
haben einen grossen Einfluss darauf,
ob junge Athletinnen eine ungesunde
Beziehung zum Essen entwickeln.
Das ist so eine Sache:
Man muss muskulös sein.
Man braucht ja Muskeln,
um diesen Sport zu machen.
Aber gleichzeitig
sollte man nicht muskulös aussehen.
Man muss ja
schön ästhetisch aussehen.
Die Muskeln müssen lang sein,
nicht kurzgezogen.
Die perfekte Synchronschwimmerin
ist halt megadünn und megagross
mit riesenlangen Beinen.
Man wurde von Kopf bis Fuss
betrachtet und es wurde gesagt:
"Das und das musst du verändern."
"Deine Arme sind etwas dick."
Dazu kommt körperliche Gewalt,
die für viele Synchronschwimmerinnen
noch immer
zum Trainingsalltag gehört.
Flaschen anwerfen, Klemmen
und v.a. das gewaltsame Dehnen.
Was mich immer extrem schockierte,
passierte bei Aline.
Im Mittelspagat.
Sie lag auf dem Rücken
und hatte die Beine so gespreizt,
um für den Mittelspagat zu dehnen.
Dann stand unsere Trainerin
mit ihrem ganzen Gewicht
auf ihre Oberschenkel.
Ich kriegte rechts Hüftprobleme usw.
Ich wusste,
dass das im Training kam.
Selbst wenn sie wusste,
dass es einem wehtat ...
Natürlich wusste sie das.
Man sass dann einfach
3 Min. weinend am Boden
und sie stand auf einem drauf.
Das ist ihnen egal.
Es ist egal, ob du weinst.
- Sie hacken immer darauf rum.
Sagte man "Stopp!", war das egal.
Man hatte ihr nichts zu sagen.
Sagt man: "Kannst du aufhören?",
drückte sie extra stärker.
Man wird von ihr trainiert
und nicht umgekehrt.
Wir hatten alle schon Verletzungen
wegen solcher Dinge -
v.a. Muskelrisse, Zerrungen.
Gebrochen haben sie mir nichts.
Es schwingt immer diese Angst mit,
dass man ersetzt werden kann.
In einem Team können acht schwimmen.
Z.T. hat man vier Reserve,
z.T. zwei.
Man weiss, dass man bei
einer Verletzung rausgenommen wird -
mit der Möglichkeit,
nicht mehr reinzukommen.
Die Emotionen kontrollieren,
lächeln - trotz allem.
Wie hier an der WM in Gwangju 2019.
Mit im Team: Anouk Helfer.
* Dynamische Musik *
Mir jagte es bei Verletzungen
die Sicherung raus.
Da dachte ich: "Das war fahrlässig."
Als du zurückkamst und
dein ganzer Gesässmuskel gerissen
und die Schulter kaputt war,
weil du immer
der Bock sein musstest.
Sie nahmen keine Rücksicht
auf so was.
In Tenero
schwammen sie bei Blitz und Donner.
Ich musste fünfmal anrufen,
bis jemand
die Mädchen aus dem Wasser holte.
Die hatten teilweise Panik.
Das war das normale Synchro-Leben.
Es war nichts Neues,
wenn es etwas strenger, lauter wurde
oder wenn einem auch mal
eine Flasche angeworfen wurde.
Was?
- Oder ein Löffel. Was auch immer.
Das hat sie nie erzählt.
- Das war nicht so ...
Das gibt es halt.
Das ist das Synchro-Leben.
Ich weiss,
dass du manchmal Angst hattest,
ins Training oder in die Lager
zu gehen.
Ich fragte mich immer:
"Warum machst du es dann?"
Aber als Aussenstehende ...
Also, "Aussenstehende" ...
Wenn man nicht dabei ist,
ist es schwierig, das zu verstehen.
Ich kann das gar nicht beschreiben,
aber ich hatte nicht so ...
... Lust, darüber zu sprechen.
Es war mehr:
Das war im Training und ich wollte
mich nicht damit beschäftigen.
Ich wollte es -
so gut wie möglich - vergessen,
weitermachen
und nicht zurückschauen.
Sie sagten: "Denkt nicht, Anrufe
der Eltern machen da etwas besser."
Im Gegenteil.
Sie verpassten uns einen Maulkorb.
- Sie drohten.
Eine Schwimmerin
erzählte es trotzdem ihrer Mami.
Am nächsten Morgen im Training
war die Stimmung sehr angespannt.
Dann mussten wir Runden rennen.
Eine Trainerin
nahm dann ein Mädchen raus.
Sie waren 20 Min. draussen
und das Mädchen kam weinend rein.
Wir fragten, was los sei.
"Meine Mutter hat sie angerufen."
Sie war dann wütend auf ihre Mami,
weil sie nichts sagen sollte.
Die Trainerinnen,
die "SRF Investigativ"
mit den Vorwürfen konfrontiert hat,
wollen keine Stellung nehmen.
Es betrifft auch nicht
alle Trainerinnen in der Schweiz.
Aber doch offenbar so viele,
dass von einem systemischen Problem
auszugehen ist.
Was immer wieder angesprochen wird:
die osteuropäische
und russische Trainingsmentalität.
Die Russen
sind mit Abstand die Besten.
Dass die Russen anders trainiert
und getrimmt werden, weiss jeder.
Da lernt man sehr schnell:
"Sie ist der Chef."
Unsere Trainerinnen
können dann sagen,
wir müssten
zu den Russen aufschauen.
Die erreichen alles und sind
mit 97 von 100 Punkten fast perfekt.
Das hinterfragt man dann nicht,
weil man auch dorthin kommen will.
Wenn es heisst,
die würden so trainieren -
warum
sollte man sich dagegenstellen?
Dann macht man das halt auch so.
Die grosse Frage, die sich stellt:
Warum hört man nicht einfach auf?
Man könnte ja sagen:
"Nächste Woche komme ich nicht mehr."
Man wird erfolgreich,
hat Schweizermeistertitel,
Vizeschweizermeister,
kommt in die Nati, WM usw. -
es funktioniert, warum
sollte man das also hinterfragen?
Bis es einem
irgendwann so schlecht geht ...
Und man stellt
sein ganzes Leben dafür um.
Man geht an eine Sportschule,
stimmt die Schule darauf ab,
schaut, dass man noch dort und dort
mit dem Zug hinkommt.
Und das Team
ist wirklich deine zweite Familie.
Man verspürt von allen Seiten
Druck -
von diesen Leuten,
die alle Erwartungen an dich haben.
Man kann die
nicht einfach alle enttäuschen.
Man identifiziert sich damit.
Die Leute würde man alle verlieren,
wenn man aufhört.
Es ist kein Hobby.
Es ist dein Leben.- Ja.
Im Herbst 2020 gab es schon einen
riesigen Knall im Schweizer Sport.
Es wurden Missstände
im Kunstturnen
und in der Rhythmischen
Sportgymnastik aufgedeckt -
die sog. Magglingen-Protokolle.
Es gab einen Aufschrei,
die Politik reagierte.
Bundesrätin Viola Amherd
zeigte sich persönlich betroffen.
Für mich war klar,
dass wir diese Vorfälle
nicht tolerieren dürfen
und wir alles daransetzen müssen,
dass so etwas in Zukunft
nicht mehr vorkommt.
Bundesrätin Amherd rief
eine neue Beschwerdestelle ins Leben
und gab auch ein Gutachten
in Auftrag.
Dieses zeigte grobe Verstösse
in mehreren Sportarten.
Wörtlich: "Artistic Swimming" -
so wird Synchronschwimmen
offiziell genannt -
schnitt am schlechtesten ab.
Im Gutachten ist die Rede von:
Auch physische Gewalt wird erwähnt,
anzügliche Bemerkungen
und Dauerbelastungen.
Am Schluss heisst es, dass ...
Das war im letzten Herbst.
Was das Gutachten des Bundes
auch zeigt:
Viele Synchronschwimmerinnen
werden nebst allem anderen
auch vernachlässigt und ignoriert -
als Strafe im Training,
oder wenn sie mit 17, 18
plötzlich als zu alt gelten
oder vielleicht auch als zu fraulich.
Dann werden sie
aufs Abstellgleis geschoben.
Bei mir war das direkt nach der WM.
Ich hatte noch grosse Ziele.
Dann kamen wir
in den Club in Bern zurück.
Es fing damit an,
dass man uns nicht mehr beachtete.
Im Training
standen wir zu zweit am Rand
und sollten einander trainieren
und korrigieren.
Und die anderen trainierten
mit unserer Haupttrainerin.
Im Vereinsvorstand
wurden die Rollen getauscht
und so kamen einige Mamis
von Schwimmerinnen an die Macht.
Dann drehte sich so ziemlich alles
nur noch um die Schwimmerinnen.
Als wir etwas sagten,
wurde das entweder nicht verstanden
oder sehr abrupt abgelehnt.
Obwohl wir grosse Ziele hatten
und in unserer besten Form waren:
Wir wurden einfach
beiseitegeschoben.
Wir verliessen unseren Club
freiwillig.
Also, "freiwillig" ...
Sie ekelten und mobbten uns raus.
Anouk, Fabienne und Aline
wechselten in der Folge den Verein,
von Bern zu Basel.
Karrieremässig sei es für sie
als Nationalkader-Schwimmerinnen
trotzdem abwärtsgegangen, sagen sie.
Wir trugen diesen Stempel,
bis wir aufhörten.
Es ist schon frustrierend.
Zehn Jahre lang gab man alles dafür,
um ein gutes Image zu haben
und damit dich die Richter kennen,
und dann bist du weg vom Fenster,
weil du nicht mehr konntest
und den Club gewechselt hast.
Der Verein Synchro Bern
weist in einer Stellungnahme
die Vorwürfe zurück:
Ebenso schreibt der Verein,
es sei ...
Auch die Vorwürfe, dass Kinder von
Vorstandsmitgliedern bevorzugt würden
oder Trainerinnen psychische
und physische Gewalt anwendeten,
werden zurückgewiesen.
Wir sprachen mit vielen aktiven
und ehemaligen Synchronschwimmerinnen
aus der ganzen Schweiz.
Die meisten erzählen sehr Ähnliches.
Dazu gehören auch Vorwürfe,
die tief in die Strukturen des
Synchronschwimmens blicken lassen.
Es geht um Vetternwirtschaft,
etwa um Eltern und Trainerinnen,
die an Wettkämpfen
auch als Richter werten.
Es wird nicht
nach der Leistung benotet.
Sie laufen ein
und haben noch nicht angefangen,
aber die Richter
gehen mit den Noten rauf.
Wenn die Eltern so weit oben sind
und so viel zu sagen haben,
achten sie auf ihr Kind
oder auf ihren Verein.
Und nicht darauf, was am besten
für die Schweiz wäre.- Für alle.
Auch bei den Selektionen
für das Nati-Team:
Man schwimmt rein und sieht
drei Mütter von Schwimmerinnen.
Das kann ja nicht fair sein.
Das war immer ein Problem
in diesem Sport.
Es hiess dann: "Okay, gut."
Aber es wurde viel verdreht
und dann noch hintenherum gemacht.
Das Bemerkenswerte ist:
Die Probleme
sind offiziell festgehalten.
"SRF Investigativ" liegen interne
Dokumente des Schwimmverbands vor.
In einem Schreiben vom Mai
ist z.B. die Rede
vom "katastrophalen Niveau
bei den Richtern".
Eigene Vereine würden systematisch
und hemmungslos bevorteilt,
ebenso eigene Athletinnen.
Der Verband
schreibt von Chaos, Querelen,
unzumutbaren Arbeitsbedingungen.
Die administrative Arbeit
bleibe grösstenteils unbearbeitet,
die Planungsarbeit
sei systematisch zu spät.
Brisant:
Schon im letzten Sommer
schreibt der Schwimmverband
von "grosser Sorge um die Zukunft
von Artistic Swimming".
Es herrsche seit Jahren
ein Klima der Missgunst.
U.a. im Fokus:
die beiden Co-Sportdirektoren,
die innerhalb des Schwimmverbands
für Synchronschwimmen zuständig sind:
Markus Thöni und Patricia Fahrni.
Beide sind verbunden mit zwei
der grössten Vereine in der Schweiz:
Zürich und Morges.
Beide sind als Eltern reingerutscht.
Auch Vorwürfe von Vereinen
und Athletinnen aus dem Nationalkader
sind heftig:
Die beiden Co-Sportdirektoren
haben zu den Vorwürfen
schriftlich Stellung genommen:
Es sei nach dem Gutachten des Bundes
ein Massnahmenplan erstellt worden.
Zu Chaos und Querelen schreiben
Markus Thöni und Patricia Fahrni:
Zum Vorwurf der systematischen
und hemmungslosen Bevorteilung:
Auch betonen beide:
Kurz nach dieser Stellungnahme
gaben Markus Thöni und Patricia
Fahrni ihren Rücktritt bekannt.
Der Verband selber
hatte schon zuvor beschlossen,
die ganze Sportart
einer Analyse zu unterziehen,
wie Verbands-Co-Präsident
Ewen Cameron sagt.
Durch diesen Rücktritt
können wir jetzt -
unbelastet
von der vorherigen Situation -
aufgrund der Empfehlungen,
die uns der Bericht
hoffentlich liefern wird ...
... die Sportart neu strukturieren
und neu aufstellen.
Die Organisationsform,
das Personal ...
So hoffen wir,
Ruhe in das Ganze zu bringen.
Dass das ganze System
Synchronschwimmen nicht funktioniert,
kriegten auch Aline,
Anouk und Fabienne zu spüren.
Sie beschwerten sich
nicht nur beim Verein in Bern,
sondern auch
bei den Co-Sportdirektoren,
bei
der verbandseigenen Beschwerdestelle
und beim Verband selber.
Viele Mails seien geschrieben worden,
passiert sei letztlich wenig.
Verein und Schwimmverband
betonen heute,
man würde die Angelegenheit nach
wie vor gerne auf gute Art lösen.
Welche Hoffnungen hattet ihr?
Dass uns jemand zuhört.
Wir hatten
nicht mal die Möglichkeit,
uns mit ihnen hinzusetzen
und die Probleme zu schildern
und zu erklären.
Dass es irgendwelche Massnahmen gibt
oder etwas unternommen wird,
davon konnte man nur träumen.
Das war so weit weg.
V.a. auch, um mit der Sache
abschliessen zu können.
Das läuft jetzt schon so lange ...
Das zog sich jetzt zwei Jahre hin.
Nicht nur der Schwimmverband
erscheint passiv,
auch die neue Beschwerdestelle
Swiss Sport Integrity,
die Bundesrätin Amherd ins Leben rief
und die seit Januar in Betrieb ist,
scheint wenig niederschwellig.
* Klingelton *
Grüezi, hier ist Julia Helfer.
Haben wir
schon miteinander gesprochen?
Es geht
um die Synchronschwimmerinnen.
Ich wollte eine Meldung
bei der neuen Stelle machen.
Bis jetzt lief nichts.
Wir wissen nicht, an wen wenden.
Wir haben schon hundertmal
dasselbe erzählt.
Das braucht so viel Energie,
immer wieder dasselbe zu erzählen.
Dann erzählen die Mädchen wieder.
Ich habe jetzt gesagt,
ich mache das im Namen der Mädchen,
damit sie etwas geschützt sind.
Ich habe sie nicht gezählt,
aber das ist ein Teil des Ganzen.
Das sind gefühlt 100 Mails,
50 Anrufe ...
Man hat immer die Hoffnung,
dass sich jemand dem Fall annimmt
und uns zuhört.
Bis heute hat Swiss Sport Integrity
viele Mails geschrieben,
aber - so sagen Fabienne,
Anouk und Aline -
sie habe die drei Athletinnen
nicht einmal selber angehört.
Ernst König ist Direktor
von Swiss Sport Integrity.
Er kennt den Fall,
aber ihm seien die Hände gebunden.
Obwohl die drei bis vor Kurzem
noch im Nationalkader schwammen,
liegt der Knatsch mit dem Verein
zu weit zurück.
Das Ethik-Statut,
auf das wir uns heute stützen,
ist erst seit dem 1. Januar
in Kraft.
Darum fanden diese Vorfälle
leider ausserhalb
dieses Ethik-Statuts statt
und somit auch ausserhalb
unserer Zuständigkeit.
Rein juristisch.
Es ist mir aber wichtig,
Folgendes zu betonen:
Obwohl das nicht in
unserem Zuständigkeitsbereich ist,
unternahmen wir
sehr grosse Anstrengungen,
um dort im Sinne der Sache
eine Lösung herbeizuführen.
Wir versuchten,
zwischen den Parteien zu vermitteln.
Schlussendlich war es leider so,
dass das nicht gefruchtet hat.
Darum kam es zu keiner Einigung.
Ist es für Sie nachvollziehbar,
dass junge Athletinnen,
die nach eigenen Aussagen
stossende Dinge erlebt haben,
sich ungehört
und nicht ernst genommen fühlen?
Das kann ich sehr gut
nachvollziehen.
Es ist auch richtig,
dass man die Situation,
die wir in der Schweiz hatten,
kritisiert.
Man darf und soll,
m u s s  das sogar kritisieren.
Das hatte eben genau
keine rechtliche Grundlage.
Aber dass wir
in dieser Situation sind, zeigt,
dass im Schweizer Sport
vieles im Argen lag.
Aber man hat versucht,
das jetzt zu reparieren.
Seit dem 1. Januar
sind wir in einer anderen Situation.
Wären die Vorfälle jetzt passiert,
wäre klar, dass wir zuständig sind.
Dann hätten wir das untersucht - und
dazu gehört eine Anhörung der Opfer.
Habt ihr das Gefühl, in der Karriere
etwas verpasst zu haben?
Ich finde schon.
Wären wir weiter gefördert worden,
wäre alles ganz anders.
Wir wären sicher weiter in der Nati.
- Ja.
Wir wären mit der Nati an andere
grosse Wettkämpfe gegangen.
Das wurde uns einfach genommen.
Irgendwann
hatten wir keine Kraft mehr.
Wenn ihr in ein paar Jahren
selber Kinder habt
und sie Synchronschwimmen wollen:
Was würdet ihr ihnen sagen?
(Fabienne und Aline) Nein.
- Das ist schwierig.
Jeder andere Sport,
aber nicht Synchronschwimmen.
Meiner Meinung nach.
Es ist so cool, das zu machen.
Aber mit dem ganzen Drumherum ...
Ich möchte nicht, dass mein Kind
dasselbe erleben muss wie ich.
Fabienne
hat seit ihrem Rücktritt im März
fast keine Erinnerungen
ans Synchronschwimmen mehr
in ihrem Zimmer.
Nur wenige Fotos sind geblieben.
Und die Frage,
ob sie etwas verpasst hat.
Ich glaube schon.
V.a., was meine Freizeit angeht.
Ich kann jetzt nach der Schule
mit meinen Freudinnen Dinge machen.
Das konnte ich nie,
weil ich immer ins Training musste.
Das ist schade.
Diese Zeit kriegt man nicht mehr.
Es ist mehr als nur ein Hobby.
Das war wie ihre zweite Familie.
Sie war dort wie ...
Du hast nicht weniger Zeit
dort verbracht als hier.- Nein.
Und dann
muss man plötzlich spüren ...
... dass es reicht,
dass jetzt die Nächsten drankommen.
"Ihr müsst ja nicht ..."
"Ihr könnt ein bisschen selber."
Das war schon schlimm für sie -
und natürlich auch für uns.
Natürlich. Zwangsläufig.
Ich weiss nicht, wie du das siehst.
Es ist natürlich so:
Wenn man im Training ist,
macht man etwas
mit seinen Teamkameraden.
Man möchte etwas erreichen.
Man hat ein Ziel.
Zu Hause
lernt oder schläft man meistens.
Oder man sitzt im Auto,
um ins Training zu kommen.
Man verbrachte fast mehr Zeit
mit dem Team als mit der Familie.
Ja.
- Ja.
Für Aline hat
ein neuer Lebensabschnitt angefangen.
Einer, in dem sie nun plötzlich
viel Zeit hat.
Zeit, um zurückzuschauen,
aber v.a. auch Zeit,
um nach vorne zu schauen.
Anouk wollte weit weg von der Schweiz
und vom Synchronschwimmen.
Also reiste sie Anfang Jahr für
einen Sprachaufenthalt in die USA.
Mit Bill May, ihrem grossen Vorbild,
einer amerikanischen
Synchronschwimm-Legende,
hat sie nun,
nach ein paar Monaten Auszeit,
wieder angefangen zu trainieren.
Anouk überlegt, sich für
den Cirque du Soleil zu bewerben.
Dort gibt es eine Wassershow
namens "O",
in der ihr Trainingspartner Bill
lange zur Besetzung gehörte.
Harte Arbeit, sagt Bill,
aber die könne durchaus Spass machen.
Dieser Sport
lässt dich ständig wachsen.
Er inspiriert dich.
Du siehst immer deutlicher,
was du besser machen kannst.
Und du wirst künstlerisch
herausgefordert.
Das führt zu immer neuer Motivation.
An der Westküste der USA,
in San José,
südlich von San Francisco,
ist Anouk auf der Suche nach etwas,
was ihr abhandengekommen ist:
nach der Leidenschaft
für den Tanz im Wasser.
You're very straight like that.
Hier ist das
mit einer Megafreude verbunden.
Auch, wenn ich letztes Jahr
vielleicht fitter war
und mir Dinge einfacher fielen,
machte es mir weniger Freude
als hier.
Auch, wenn es megastreng ist,
macht es enorm Freude.
Dass ich mit Bill trainieren kann,
ist eine grosse Chance.
Die Freude am Synchro
wieder zu haben, ist megaschön.
Bill May muss zur Arbeit,
also übernimmt Heather Carrasco,
die in den 90er-Jahren für die USA
eine olympische Goldmedaille
im Synchronschwimmen gewonnen hat.
* Dynamische Musik *
Anouk will wieder in Topform kommen
für ihre Bewerbung
beim Cirque du Soleil.
Dafür brauche es v.a. Motivation,
nicht Demütigung,
sagt ihre Trainerin.
Manchmal muss man
seine Stimme heben,
damit sie etwas ein bisschen besser
oder genauer im Takt machen.
Wenn man es ihnen
immer und immer wieder sagt,
wird man schon mal ein wenig lauter.
Das kann helfen, wenn man es
in einer positiven Art tut.
Aber ich denke definitiv nicht,
dass es den Schwimmerinnen hilft,
bessere Athletinnen zu werden,
wenn man sie anschreit.
* Dynamische Musik *
In den USA hat Anouk das
chinesische Essen für sich entdeckt.
Heute sagt ihr niemand mehr,
was sie darf und was sie nicht darf.
Anouk ist jetzt frei.
Sie kann tun und lassen,
und ja, auch essen, was sie will.
Eine ganz neue Erfahrung
für die heute 21-Jährige -
und manchmal auch eine Überforderung.
Es ist einerseits cool,
aber andererseits
stresst mich das auch,
weil ich eben so frei bin und mir
niemand auf die Finger schaut.
Wenn ich esse,
denke ich mir nichts dabei.
Aber nach dem Essen
fühle ich mich manchmal so:
"Vielleicht hätte ich
weniger essen sollen."
Frei sein und sich frei fühlen
ist nicht das Gleiche -
noch nicht.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022